[Music]
right now investigators trying to
determine what caused that transformer
to explode at hoover dam this is our top
story this afternoon thank you for
joining us i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian casa as well that explosion
jolting visitors at the national
landmark this morning the 8 news now
i-team's david charns with what happens
next and of course reaction
we're on i-11 overlooking hoover dam and
you can see some of the firefighting
debris left from where this transformer
exploded this morning
a startling sight tuesday morning at
hoover dam when a transformer explodes
[Music]
fire and smoke pouring from equipment
outside one of the buildings housing the
dam's hydroelectric turbines this photo
from the bureau of reclamation which
runs the dam showing just how quickly it
was doused with water by the time nearby
boulder city firefighters arrived the
fire was out i think i was a little bit
afraid if i see it the majority of
tourists taking in the sights tuesday
having no clue an explosion had even
occurred i think the people are afraid
that happened something with them i'm
sure it would be a cool sight but it's
definitely concerning
because it's a pretty important
landmark for las vegas bureau of
reclamation of course looking into what
sparked this explosion no word yet on
that and power not affected here at the
dam at all everything back to normal
we're at hoover dam i'm david charns
live local now
david thank you for that well no one was
hurt in the explosion and as you heard
david mentioned the operation at the dam
was not affected and tours even resumed
when the fire was out